question for you you know Moeller has
been looking at the russia issue since
May of 2017 you've now have to the House
and Senate Intel committee is
essentially reaching the same conclusion
if motor doesn't give Democrats anything
does this look like a witch-hunt if they
continue that investigation they're
falling into this trap this is a major
loss for Democrats and it hasn't been
reported on all we've heard about for
two years is Russia Russia Russia it
appears to have turned up nothing
the 800-page Manafort report turned up
no evidence of collusion between trump
or russia and so the Senate Intelligence
Committee said the same thing so now
they are turning to his private business
dealings or who he gave security
clearances to or a casino he wanted to
build in 1982 or whatever and it just
makes people think ah you've come to a
conclusion and now you are in search of
an argument to support that conclusion
it looks like a witch hunt though I
agree with Sarah Sanders I don't see any
other strategy for 2020 Democrats
because they can't run on green new deal
they'll get blown out of the water they
can't run on totally socialist medicine
they'll get blown out of the water so
all they can do is attack the president
even if it makes them look like cynical
witch hunters